les gars les gars vous avez vu damien je
crois que il va allumer l'un d'entre
nous aujourd'hui et je pense qu'il va
choisir parce que j'ai vu pas mal de ses
potes connecter sur fifa sans vouloir
t'offenser xbox one il en train de jouer
à final fantasy 7 le remake en ce moment
ça son jeu préféré je pense qu'ils
peuvent choisir
désolé ouais bah il va peut-être me
choisir c'est possible switch laisse
nous parler entre grands en fait oui on
t'appellera concernés à se voudra jouer
à mario kart bages et d'autres jeux main
georges et marie-aude icg mario party
tennis regarder des mails s'approche il
vient vers moi
il vient vers moi et oui il m'a choisi
parce qu'on était en train de jouer un
super jeu un couac s'appellerait au
[ __ ] il vient de débrancher ps4 oui et
alors genre moi il me branche il me
débranche tout le temps que je vois mais
non mais toi tu as aussi une console
portable ça compte pas à nous on est
j'ai fixé au truc
attendez attendez ok ok il rend branche
presse café robes rouges pascal bats tpr
auch et le coup ça fait quand même temps
je suis partir d'un an qu'elle avait
paquet pescade ça fait même pas deux
minutes bon retour parmi nous et
attendit nickel mois novembre au merde
c'est la sortie des nouvelles consoles
putelat pessac la nouvelle xbox c'est le
nexen vous pensez que jamais elle a
commandé une nouvelle console mais bien
sûr je très bien elle achète toujours la
nouvelle console quand ils sortent
moyens d'acheter la sortie ps4 et la
baisse ses prix c'est comme ça c'est
vrai ça c'est trop cool on va avoir un
nouveau peu mais non mais non soyez je
suis pas cool
il ya deux scénarios pour l'un d'entre
nous soyez revendu entre autres dans le
carton la honte
ah ouais mais oui les gars j'ai eu chaud
au cul lui en prit jette pas n'est-ce
regarder les vieux comme le monde allait
prendre la place excusez moi on va se
calmer tout de suite je suis le doyen
ici donc vous me devez le respect alors
n'ai je sais pas si ce n'est au courant
mais nintendo a fait une réédition de
toi en minimes pas cherchez pas ce que
tu fous là
quand j'entends bien mais c'est la
nostalgie on a créé des liens anciens et
fort avec anthony messahel a bien oui
pardon anthony hémond anciens
propriétaires mais voilà justement
damien a voulu recréer ce lien fort et
anciens qu'il avait avec ça mais c'est
pour ça qu'ils marchaient dans une
brocante à quelques années d'ailleurs je
vous ferai remarquer que si une console
next gen arrive c'est ps4 xbox one qui
va dégager ça paraît évident je suis
vieux mais pas contre y'a pas toi me
reconnais c'est quoi ce bordel je suis
next-gen 1 et theo bos elle est ok je ne
suis pas obsolète je suis rétro
désormais il faut d'ailleurs tu étais
next gen il y à cette banque il faut
avancer mais je suis quoi alors eh ben
tu es juste jeunes des justes gênant
même très bon j'aime mais voilà pc qui
se l'arrachent
mais je le répète mais je sais pas
pourquoi d'année et vous garde je fais
tout comme vous mais en plus beau qu'est
ce que je dis je les raconte tellement
pcc la vérité j'y peux rien d'ailleurs
son jeu du moment c'est world of tanks
ce jeu propose des graphismes
exceptionnels damien peut piloter plus
de 600 blindés la seconde guerre
mondiale face à 160 millions de joueurs
en ligne le lien pour télécharger le jeu
et dans la description c'est gratuit la
description
je ne comprends pas de quoi ils parlent
caisse quelqu'un peut m'expliquer est un
casse à un placement de produits pc tu
coûte une fortune je connais le regard d
amiens là il en train de se dire [ __ ]
si je vends mon pc je m'achète que je
dormais d'accord c'est vrai que je suis
un peu onéreux mais je suis aussi un
outil de travail genre excellent si de
travail mon cul ouais vous pensez
vraiment que damien il a acheté une
nvidia j'ai pensé arte x 3080 pour
lancer worn n'a pas sonné smartphones on
parle de jeux vidéo tepa concert
calme-toi ps4 avec damien on joue
famille bon qu'en dit kroes ça va merci
on a force d'haïti genre smartphones il
fait tourner fortnight oui moi si je
suis ton effort tight mêmes pays b g et
on joue tout le temps dans les
transports alors j'aime à prix fixe box
one et ps4 ils sont obligés d'être
branché pour être joué
mais on dirait que le livre est arrivé
fait de la place pour une nouvelle
console mega il faut être pragmatique à
un moment c'est très simple si damien a
commandé la ps 5 c'est que dsk est
qu'ils dégagent
si la commande et la nouvelle xbox et
xbox one qui dégage car elle simple rdpc
a raison je vais dégager
ouais ça m'a fait plaisir de vous
connaître au revoir hop hop hop xbox one
il a commandé la ps 5 1 il a de très bon
goût donc c'est moi qui dégage merci les
gars ça m'a fait plaisir au revoir à
n'importe quoi il va prendre la xbox
séries6 attentes a dit qu'elle
s'appelait comment la nouvelle xbox
alors pour le non jeu peut tout
expliquer on a sorti au début la xbox
ensuite on a sorti la xbox 360 ça fait
un tour c'est stylé et à celle d'après
c'était pas la 361 ça faisait un peu
trop on est revenu à 1
on a fait la xbox one ensuite elle a
voulu faire la xbox x mais ça fait trop
de x d'affilée alors namy series au
milieu pour séparer le bx quoi c'est
plus clairement n'ont rien compris non
parce que nous c'est plus simple on a
fait playstation 1 2 3 4 5 c'est carré
d'ailleurs il existe une ps 500 lecteurs
de disques qui est encore moins chère à
nous aussi on a exactement pareil on à
la xbox série s qui n'a pas de lecteur
cd elle est moins chère elle est un
petit peu moins puissant xbox série s
vous pensez vraiment que damien il va
acheter une console next-gen mais pas
trop trop next-gen non plus genre il
achète une ferrari mais qui galère un
peu sur l'autoroute bien sûr attendait
parce que s'il choisit une console sans
le lecteur de cd ça veut dire qu'ils
téléchargent les jeux donc les jeux sont
moins chers donc c'est pas mal mais
qu'est ce que tu as construit tu vas
s'il achète pas le céder ils n'achètent
pas la boîte le petit livre et la
logistique la marge magasins dont ils
payent moins cher le jeu vivant dans ces
80 euros what quatre balles ah oui c'est
plus que m'ont prié les jeux soit 80
bale maintenant
non mais écoutez damien va prendre la
ps5 déjà on appela les exclus final
fantasy
fort d'un mario spider man on a racheté
l'éditeur de skyrim et fallout ballot
god of war peut-être non mais alors quoi
allez on a des atouts non je déconne en
a marre xbox on était au courant que
damas il peut jouer à tous les jeux avec
moi tu le sais ça
je crois qu'il ya un problème avec xbox
il ne répond plus n'aurait fait une mise
à jour d'ailleurs ça dérange pas je vais
en profiter pour faire la mienne at il
[Musique]
dit est ce que c'est normal que le
livreur et une dizaine d'années à non
mais ça c'est pas un livreur c'est la
nièce de damien parfois ils jouent tous
les deux ensemble avec moi aimer ça se
trouve il va pas du tout à fait nouvelle
mais ce sont bel et bien tu sais comme
la dernière fois quand je t'aimais tu
écoutes je crois que j'ai encore mieux
que ça c'est bientôt l'anniversaire est
bon je suis fauchée mais j'ai un super
cadeau pour toi tu peux choisir la
console que tu veux que je suis sérieux
ok c'est bon si switch qui va dégager
quoi elle va vouloir jouer un imac ont
signé tous les miens je l'aï dit moi je
veux partir je viendrai vous voit pas la
ps4 talent à switch tu prends des beaux
graphismes prend xbox j'en fais ta
gueule quand mon nom mon petit tu me
prends pas ma propre à ces sites ici
c'est lui qu'il faut prendre du super
graphisme j'adore c'est quoi ton jeu
préféré bon je préférais c'est final
fantasy cet accord j'ai même le remake
il est rouge tient sa promesse 4 non non
non non c'est un remake c'est nul un
remake sais pas
à l'origine elle bah ouais sur
playstation attend les surcharger alors
oui c'est un peu vieillot et si tu veux
pas ici même je peux prendre la
playstation [ __ ] on l'a échappé belle
les gars où tu veux la playstation
d'accord si c'est celle que tu veux elle
est à toi j'ai comme la branche est un
point ça marche ou pas pour info moi
j'étais pas du tout inquiète et oui moi
non plus je m'en bats les couilles en
fait on
aa
j'attends son voile
ouais ça me donne les petits frison
romelu vous êtes dit ça fait quand même
jour que je débranche salut moi c'est
xbox one je te présente ps4 switch
smartphones et pc ça fait 20 ans que tu
est débranché mon pote ps4 kaka version
génial pourquoi d'avenir et bars
branchés et pourquoi il a de la baronne
alors ou bi damien t'appartient sagna ce
nom la gamine mais je veux pas jouer
avec la gamine moi c'est quoi ce bordel
vannes ont au contraire taplin d'heure
de jeu devant toi maintenance pairraud
crash bandicoot final fantasy 7 s'écoule
à temps vas-y ton à gauche ah ouais
c'est vrai d'ailleurs j'ai aussi ses
jeux en remake en plus beau c'est pour
l'anecdote en voilà ouais pourquoi tu
veux me donner une réponse hall alors
que pourtant tu les adore bah je passe
plus beaucoup de temps chez moi en ce
moment je suis 100 ch ma copine c'est la
sage femme
donc j'ai plus trop le temps de jouer à
mes consoles au [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] tu
joues plus du tout aux jeux vidéo
ainsi si le schéma copine elle appelle 5
nous abandonne c'est la vie a dans 20
ans un énorme merci à world of tanks ce
qui nous a permis de réaliser cette
vidéo est d'ailleurs vous invite à
cliquer sur un lien dans la description
pour jouer gratuitement sur pc et
d'ailleurs il ya un petit code promo si
vous créez un compte pour avoir du
contenu premium gratuit
ça fait toujours plaisir je vous dis à
très vite abonnez-vous cas
[Musique]